Brian we were able to sit down with Red
Rock search and rescue today they walked
us through exactly how these AED works
in the process of someone trying to save
another person's life
call 911
these pads come out
I'm going to pull off
so I could get the adhesive there's a
little picture they go on like so
patients and we had continued doing CPR
contribution now it says don't touch
patient the AED is looking for
ventricular fibrillation so that's
that's a shockable rhythm so people say
I'm afraid to use it I don't want to
accidentally shock somebody you can't it
only shocks and be fed so it's calling
for a shot
I'm clear you're clear everybody clear
I'm just going to follow the directions
of the AED leave the pads on because as
time goes on approximately two minutes
is going to keep looking for that v-fib
and tell me the shock again if it
detects v-fib
now in cases that these aeds are used
according to the American Heart
Association it can increase survival
rates by about 38 percent and he says
they are also used in tandem with CPR
now the American Red Cross does offer
CPR classes here locally in Las Vegas
for anyone who would like to learn
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now